pour avoir plus de pouvoir on a décidé
de marie clarisse et un riche noble et
puissant le problème c'est que son futur
époux arrive aujourd'hui est que je sais
absolument pas comment organiser ce
mariage donc on y va tempez de 10 les
cérémonies religieuses
évitez du riz au moment du gâteau un
[__] et foyot tôt commencez déjà par
me demander mon avis est ce que je peux
choisir mon mari je voudrais plus jeune
homme que j'aime et bonjour monsieur
vous avez un très très beau cheval a pas
du tout ça rien à voir c'est une chaise
oui au sérieux braga tout ça me stresse
à
c'est totalement dégueulasse on m'impose
un mari et j'ai rien le droit de dire
parce que je suis une femme c'est une
blague non en tant que senior j'ai le
droit d'ordonner ce mariage
par contre pour le gâteau j'ai vraiment
pas comment faire on pourrait peut-être
faire plusieurs tarte
ça y est un panel le dernier mariage du
royaume s'est très mal passé et quand je
dis très mal passé je parle pas de notes
oxydation alimentaire c'était un bain de
sang plantage de femmes enceintes neige
dans les yeux rachat de gore l'envié de
faire un truc un peu plus festive et
donc les mystères sont de mise
la voici à hélices notre maître d'armes
jour ses meilleurs voici liorel notre
maistre à lemaistre c'est un port de
moineaux chez bulls à d'accord
puisqu'ils n'ont si si si si bien vous
savez un guerrier je vous avais moins
d'un château une armure et tous ces
coquillages et pas [__] un ficus non
c'est juste comme chez moi abbassi
désolé mais ça ressemble tellement
d'ailleurs on se connaîtraient pas je me
dis bon hulin peut imiter le style lui
l'âge est exactement le même
en été il ya des pierres et des armures
ça se ressemble et enfin mon épouse
aller où on est poussé
salutations ok c'est bon de mariée de
force à seigneur que je découvre à peine
je trouve ça outrageant et inhumain et
mais comme c'est pour l'honneur de la
maison je me réussit bien
dès que j'ai vu le temps s'est arrêté et
j'ai tout de suite senti que j'étais
pachon ont fait une répétition du
mariage
je pensais pas que je resterai aussi
motivé c'est trop est ce qu'on est sûr
que c'est une bonne idée
la pomme dans certaines régions
aéronautique est ce qu'on sait pas un
peu précipité donné la dame de votre cou
mais moi je ne sais pas d'apprendre quoi
prix sont jamais car ils sont fous de ce
qu'on veut c'est à dire oui mais voilà
on peut se dire on peut graver salies et
voulait dire s'allier sans mariage oui
oui mais non c'est vrai qu'il t'aime tu
tout l'art fait c'est top
moi je suis ravi et maintenant je
voudrais ben parents partir très vite
ok clarisse bonne nouvelle il ya plus de
mariages à meschers alliés quelle joie
et bien votre allié ça fait deux fois
relié je suis très honoré de faire
partie 2 voilà je suis fier ma fierté
n'a de sens que cette église en chacun
de vous remercier
c'est top merci
est parti